I've been following the 2020 Democratic
primary campaign of Andrew yang with
great interest for a while now and I've
had him on the show a couple of times
and my attention yesterday was called to
an interview that Andrew yang did on the
Fox Business channel with this fat cat
Stewart Bart Varney and I call him that
because when you see this guy he is just
a caricature of the typical rich dude
fat cat who can't be bothered to think
about how it is that someone making
twenty seven thousand dollars a year is
going to live day to day and last year
he brought Andrew yang on and it was
just amazing because Andrew yang utterly
crushed Stuart Varney Varney started to
play semantic games about universal
basic income which is a big issue for
Andrew and about socialism and then when
it became clear that Andrew yang wasn't
going to be pushed around at Andrew yang
he really knows what he's talking about
Stuart Varney just starts smirking and
talking about Oh handouts and free stuff
let's take a look at this first part of
the interview and you will see very
quickly that Andrew yang is in complete
control and Stuart Varney has no idea
what to do other than to just start
repeating phrases that are read me to
the fox news audience we are the owners
and stakeholders of the society the
exact way that the owners and
stakeholders of a company receive a
dividend every quarter total socialism
socialism in you you're smart enough to
know that socialism is when and thank
you Macau is when a country nationalizes
the means of production this is any
fault this is the old market and throw
consumer Pro market yes very much so
consumer mark is here too much will he
just have to put your hand out that's
not a market well no American watching
this right now is going to quit their
job on $1,000 a month that is not enough
to do more than to survive marginally in
most any situation what they're going to
do is I'm going to take that money
they're going to start new businesses
they're going to go back to school
they're going to frequent their Main
Street economy and we're all going to be
better off for it
okay so you can see that Stuart Varney
has no idea how to respond to this
because Andrew yang is very able and
incapable of explaining that this isn't
socialism also who is going to just say
I am fine living on ten
thousand dollars a year and have no
interest in working at all most people
are not going to do that
so we're gonna continue and we're gonna
back it up a few seconds just so you can
really make sure you hear Stuart Varney
'he's next comment where we're going to
pick it up he does what is the
equivalent of the white flag when you
run out of arguments you strawman your
opponents with utopian nonsense and what
I mean by that is you're gonna hear
Stuart Varney go paradise right
it'll just be paradise if we're able to
do what you're suggesting that's what
you do when you've lost the argument
Andrew yang isn't saying 10,000 a year
of ubi is paradise he's recognizing our
problems are way bigger than just giving
everybody 10,000 bucks and he explains
that but when you see Stuart Varney say
paradise right it's because he has no
good explanation as to why this isn't a
good idea
they're going to frequent their Main
Street economy and we're all going to be
better off for it getting paradise right
well we have to start thinking bigger
about what direction we want to move in
as a society because the truth is I was
just out in Silicon Valley last month we
are going through the greatest
technological and economic shift in
human history and we need to make much
bigger moves towards an economy that's
sustainable over the long term for all
Americans what you have to understand
and I think a lot of Fox News viewers
don't when they watch this is that
Stuart Varney presents no arguments
Andrew yang proposes a policy 10,000 a
year you bi and stuart varney simply
says socialism andrew yang explains no
it's not actually socialism and stuart
varney says paradise right and andrew
yang says no i'm also not saying it's
paradise what I'm saying is most people
want to make more than 10 grand a year
10 grand a year isn't paradise we can
afford it here's how it would be good
calling Andrew yang a socialist also is
super interesting because it just
doesn't work Andrew yang is no more
socialist than Donald Trump is a
socialist these are capitalist
businesspeople the main difference is
yang understands economics and Yang's
businesses haven't declared bankruptcy
to the best of my knowledge so I really
like here Pat what Andrew yang is doing
and what's refreshing to me about him is
he doesn't do talking point games he
just talks like a normal person which is
one of the things that from
was praised for in 2016 when we
interviewed him he said when I asked him
okay well what's the plan here for
making progress and for getting into the
debates he didn't give the sort of vague
grandiose talking points he said listen
the next stage is the the Iowa caucuses
are the first test 50,000 votes would
get me enough to get momentum into the
second primary that's what I'm trying to
get and I do find that refreshing about
him yeah Andrew yang is having an open
and honest conversation from a place of
good faith and you can't say the same
thing about Stuart Varney I can kind of
understand Varney's ignorance on this
matter because you know universal basic
income is only starting to seep into the
mainstream in part because of Andrew
yang but what I can't excuse is his just
complete dismissal of it you have to be
able to take in new arguments take in
new ideas and think about them don't
just dismiss them as pie in the sky's
rainbows and butterflies like he did
there
yeah well it's Fox Business so that's
simply not going to happen really nice
job by Andrea and glad that that that
that was put in front of me over the
weekend and I look forward to seeing
what Andrew yang does next today's
program is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman if you've not already
heard about plinkus it's amazing it's an
app for your phone tablet or web browser
and what they do is they take nonfiction
books popular nonfiction critically
acclaimed nonfiction they condense the
book into a fifteen minute audio book
you get all the most important
information and insights from each book
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blinkin recent one
is a Robert Rice's new book the common
good also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month
that's be li NK is t.com /pa k ma n